one of the ideas that you have that i
think is really really fascinating is
this idea of um 20th century versus 21st
century finance
what does that mean and how do you kind
of delineate between the two
well 20th century finance to me is what
our parents did it's one income income
stream it's again what you guys talk
about with bitcoin and crypto which is
it's all about decentralization right
you don't have a single point of failure
you have multi points of failure which
allows you to have more uh safety and
security amongst other things but it's
the same with incomes so what i see is
the biggest failure and the pandemic
proved it for all of us is that most
people 1 out of 100 people will die
wealthy the rest largely die
sadly poor and i think the reason that
is is because they have a single point
of failure they have one income stream
and corporations they are incentivized
to make you have one income stream right
like employers do not like you to have
multiple jobs they do not like you to be
bitcoin rich and also work at their
company typically and so that's 20th
century income and finance in my mind
you have a single point of failure that
is your income you stay at one place and
you have a pension until you die
and 21st century is what millionaires do
today seven to 12 streams of income and
you used to think that that was so hard
to get impossible to get but it's
actually not today more than ever it's
easier to have multi-income streams in
fact you could do with a hundred dollars
by investing in something like fundrise
which is hard asset real estate in an
app you know you can do it by investing
in cryptocurrency and staking or earning
on top of them and having cash flow so
what i talk to people about is how can
you go from your one income stream and
use that one income stream to get you 10
or 12 because in my prediction it's
going to get worse not better and people
who only have one income will be the
ones left holding the bag when you think
about cash flow or income is that the
first thing like you need to have the
cash flow in order to be able to execute
any of these investing strategies
well you need
let's do it two ways one i don't like
deals where you don't get cash flow
right away that's why i'm not a big fan
of angel and investing we could talk
about that later but when it comes to um
investing today you i like to put money
down on the table and get money back day
one that's called cash flow investing
and we can talk about ways to do it it's
just that most people don't know how to
structure deals and i get it i only
learned this for being a private equity
but so so first thing is any deal you do
you should look for payment day one it
is not a good deal if you do not get
paid until 10 years because most angel
investments will go to zero not 100 x
and so you need to invest with that in
mind now you do have to have some money
to start investing typically or you can
use your sweat so it's either you have
equity or you have sweat equity and what
i talk to a lot of people about is even
if you're working with somebody even if
you have a job you like your job you
want to stay there you should be trying
to move towards ownership instead of
employment and you can do that as an
employee by asking for things like
revenue share where you take a
percentage of the revenue that you help
bring into the company or profit share
which is probably more likely
when you think about the first deal you
did walk us through how did you find the
deal
how did you negotiate it and then do you
still hold it did you think about
selling it at some point like how do you
think about like what the end of that uh
that investment looks like
yeah so the first deal that i did by
myself completely uh i still hold it was
a terrible deal i won't say the name of
the company because i don't want to hurt
the operator's feelings it was a
terrible terrible deal um i went and
it's like sort of the five tenants that
i talk about now i bought a company that
was too big uh because i was cocky uh
and so it could have broke me i could
have lost all my money doing this first
deal um the accountant left basically
two weeks in so i'm in like a dusty room
full of ledgers trying to figure out
what the heck is going on with the
service-based business um and they're a
mess the operator uh was not trusted
talent or tried talent meaning i didn't
know the operator and he hadn't done the
job before which is now something i look
for with every deal and then lastly i
had invested in what it's called a
turnaround business this is what the
biggest issue that young people do is we
get all excited we're like i'm gonna go
buy a small business look at that
laundromat over there it's a nightmare
it's dirty like the machines are old i'm
going to totally redo all of it small
problem
never ran a business before never ran a
laundromat before never turned around in
business before so that's like the
people who go and buy houses that are
nightmares and then they want to flip it
and their first slip is usually a
disaster because you have no idea what
you're doing uh and so instead you
should take a little bit of the safer
bet on the first one and then go do it's
called a hairy deal then go do a hairy
deal that's a little bit harder as you
go but that was my first deal now 12
years later uh the deal is profitable
it's a win it's good to go which is why
i like to do i think it was like naval
that said not long-term deals with
long-term people i like to do the same
thing with my businesses find good ones
hold them forever never let go of the
cash flow why do you hold so much cash
well it's a dichotomy today right like
somebody asked the question they were
like how can you
how is it that cash is king and that
also cash is trash because of inflation
and i was like the truth is it is both
it is literally both today you need to
have a way to protect the cash that you
have from inflation and the fact that
our government's printing debt like it's
going out of style or printing money
like it's going on style but you also
have to have cash because in my belief
you want to do what baron rothschild
said which is buy when there's blood in
the streets especially when it's yours
and so if you think like me that the
world will not always continue to be you
know at all-time highs eventually the
dance will end you want cash because
illiquid assets won't allow you to take
advantage of it and if you look like
it's actually i should have brought the
stats but you could google it um if you
look at
vc
private equity uh funds and the vintages
or the years that they start investing
during recessionary periods those are
always the best performing funds so you
want money that you can access the
second things go sideways which is why
you need cash but you also need things
to offset inflation like crypto real
estate uh different types of cash
flowing assets and small businesses
we've got a whole bunch of ideas that
you sent me in advance of things that
people can do in order to
buy businesses or sectors that could be
interesting for them to kind of get
started and make it actionable uh the
first one is modular homes and you wrote
just in all caps the future so what what
is modular homes in terms of being the
future and what do you think people
could do there
well i think we're a ways away from it
still so excuse the enthusiasm but for
instance i get really excited whenever i
can buy something that i'm a value
investor in a way a value cash flowing
investor which is not usually normal so
whenever somebody says there's a market
like real estate at all-time highs i
mean we just bought a property in austin
it's absolute chaos down there um
i'm always looking for how can i get
into the asset class but in the cheapest
way possible and so modular homes are
essentially these 3d printed homes or
factory built homes factory built is
more normalized that are made for
quite a lot cheaper than the average so
our house that we bought so we bought a
house in a mountain town and it's on
about an acre of land and with a house
it was like 3000 square feet i think the
whole thing was we bought about we
bought it for about 900k
now in this mountain town the average
home price is about 2.1 2.3 million i
can't remember the exact amount so
somehow i am able to get in at a bigger
plot of land in a great location with a
price tag that's about half uh more than
half um less than half of the price of
traditional real estate and the reason
why is because modular home developments
are new so modular homes you going out
right now and buying a factory home you
can see them they're all over pinterest
everybody thinks they look cool
but you do not want to buy a singular
modular home because it doesn't scale as
well what you need to do is go out and
find developers in the us that are
building modular home developments their
economies of scale for massive factory
printing will mean that you can buy at
one third to one half the price and if i
was a developer i'd be doing this all
day long because the factory built homes
are cool looking
they're much more efficient because
about 70 percent of construction is
waste
it's absolutely nuts um there's a a
number of businesses i don't want to
name any of them to give free marketing
but uh
in terms of
the various businesses uh one there's a
bunch of efficiencies that they gain so
you don't get that waste on kind of
construction site but also too is i
think that there's a lot of consumer
kind of preferences changing right
people don't necessarily need uh to live
in a city so there's more demand for
people who want to go live in some of
these areas and also too is uh what type
of home do they want right and kind of
what do they need actually do they need
a seven-car garage probably not right
and so i think that you get a number of
tailwinds along with the actual unit
economics changing and it seems like
that's uh kind of a bet that you think
is worth taking
totally yeah i think um you know anytime
you get to invest in innovation at a
discount that's pretty wild um so i
think that's an opportunity the modular
home space now i haven't found that many
companies that i would invest in that
are modular home builders yet because
they haven't figured out the scale
portion of it yet but i think if you
could do a factory built home and you
could own the land and part of the
development company you could cash flow
from it today but you could also benefit
from the potential innovation going
forward because wouldn't it be crazy man
i couldn't could you imagine if you were
like what's the brand of your house you
know if it's not like where do you live
and what you know what does your house
look like it's like oh no i live in a i
live in a a pomp house right because
just like everything else
would be scary just like anything else
everything will eventually be branded
and i think your house will be too yeah
makes sense hey guys thanks so much for
watching that clip of the best business
show make sure you like and subscribe to
the channel turn on notifications so you
know when we go live every weekday and
then head to sofi.com so that you can
get an account we can get after it